salve benvenuti al primo di una serie di
video per festeggiare il milione quasi
di iscritti no dico quasi perché mentre
lo sto registrando ne mancano ancora 400
quindi grazie mille queste 400 persone
che si sono iscritte perché mi ha
permesso di fare il video uno dei modi
con cui vorrei festeggiare e vederli e
quale modo migliore per vedervi sennò
con uno spettacolo di per i pubblici io
insieme al buon vincenzo faremo un mini
tour di tre date con tre serate in tre
teatri incredibili o e per chi non lo
sapesse se stiamo portando in giro uno
spettacolo ecco il trailer
diciamo che mi piacerebbe guadagnare
tanto senza fare un cazzo nella vita
quindi un anno e qualcosa fa ho aperto
un canale youtube una dottoressa per lei
era tutto psicosomatico cesa
professionista sono malata di cancro
no se tuo figlio un giorno chi dicesse
che dei ma che cazzo domanda è questa
l'ho capita
siamo qua
perché sono un [ __ ]
fammi spiegare prima
sì il trailer che ha fatto la sindone è
molto ma molto più bello di quello che è
lo spettacolo alla fine però se volete
esserci league dei biglietti nelle
informazioni e nelle info vi lascio
anche il link del mio sito che abbiamo
creato da poco è fatto esclusivamente a
posto per trovare le date del tour
che altro dire se volete venire a vedere
uno spettacolo dissacrante e irriverente
senza peli sulla lingua
state a casa perché il nostro non è così
ci vediamo lì in teoria vito dovrebbe
finire qui ma chi vuole ancora aspettare
un minutino mi piacerebbe raccontarvi la
mia esperienza con per i pubblici è
sempre stato il mio sogno fare comicità
dal vivo stand up comedy bla bla bla bla
bla ma come era all'inizio perché io
avevo preparato agli inizi proprio
quando ho fatto il primo spettacolo a
torino un'ora di materiale senza mai
essere stato sul palco e senza mai aver
neanche provato quel materiale è la
prima serata è stata ok pubblico si è
divertito ma io ho sentito che quel
materiale non poteva funzionare
totalmente così però detto va bene
proviamo le ho fatto altre serate
piccoli in eni in un locale di torino in
cui di solito si fa musica dal vivo ma
ho detto ma sai cosa è ottimo per video
stronzate e tutte le serate sono andate
bene so che il materiale era ancora un
po troppo incastrato in se stesso poi
arrivata l'occasione di provarlo a bari
in una sala cinematografica da 300
persone per due spettacoli nello stesso
giorno e le sale cinematografiche
la piccola particolarità le noci non
sono fatte apposta per uno spettacolo e
c'erano solo due opzioni o tutti al buio
o tutti illuminati e quindi io ho visto
per due volte nello stesso giorno 300
facce di 300 persone diverse che stavano
ascoltando quello che dicevo è stato
molto bello e ho detto e lo spettacolo
funzionicchia c'è qualcosa che non mi
convince però è bene che io lo schiaffo
valore
poi ho conosciuto vincenzo che vi ha
detto fai quello alta mi piacerebbe fare
qui non lo facciamo insieme e io ho
detto va bene abbiamo creato una serata
qui a torino dove lui ha parlato di
inculate io ho parlato di gay e tutti
erano ubriachi la serata è andata bene
tanto che lui mi ha detto è stato bello
lo rifacciamo e io ho detto ok e lui mi
ha detto però a roma che non ci sbatte
divenne fino a torino però poi io mi
sono preso una piccola pausa ho detto
devo modificare e cambiare il materiale
piuttosto che fare un'ora scialacqua ta
faccio 40 45 minuti di materiale pieno
per un po non ho fatto niente finché voi
non mi è arrivata la chiamata dire del
sinergo che vede wifi la cosa bella la
possiamo fare insieme
io ho detto ok e così è andato
l'opportunità di provare questo
materiale in un auditorium con 550
persone
cazzo ed è stato uno dei responsi di
pubblico più belli in assoluto ha forse
è meglio testarlo ancora qualche volta e
arriva la telefonata di vincenzo che mi
dice ciao ciao ne l'avaro sfidava la
roma va bene basta che mi paghi treni in
prima classe
va bene così sono andato a 9 abbiamo
fatto tre serate di fila mercoledì
giovedì venerdì sera e non a dirlo e via
ed è stato sinceramente incredibile ed è
molto bello fare gli spettacoli in
birreria perché tutti si devono 5
[ __ ] e tra i rischi e io che non
volevo rimanere escluso dal gruppo
appena arrivato al marito chiesto scusa
mi dà il bicchiere d'acqua perché devo
prenderla tachipirina che sta poco bene
ma a parte quello io vi devo ringraziare
di cuore perché voi siete stati in ogni
singola serata il pubblico giusto il
pubblico vero non siete stati i fan che
hanno riso qualsiasi cosa perché lui fa
video su youtube e io lo seguo quindi vi
ringrazio perché è anche grazie a voi se
sono riuscito a migliorare il materiale
ripete il link per comprare i biglietti
sono nelle informazioni
io vi ringrazio ancora ci vediamo dei
prossimi lo per il milione